[Music]
why does all the ancient Egyptians go
down and beads in this version of
history there are other ancient Egyptian
cities you can in accurately depict
movie 5,000 years ago narration was
created as a crutch for those who could
not tell their stories through visuals
taco-mark Scorpion King has a
suspiciously American accent after a
vicious campaign which lasted seven long
years the Scorpion King and his army
were defeated wait a minute you can't
open this movie by showing the Scorpion
King thoroughly beating ass and then cut
to well actually the war took a long
time and he failed that is fun oh this
is spare his life and let him conquer
his enemies he will give him his soul
given there was no indication that
picking up and eating the scorpion is
what Anubis wanted him to do it's not
only amazing that he knew to do it but
it's also amazing that this isn't just
some random scorpion that just came up
out of the desert I knew this was quite
adept at CGI
or not depends on if you look at this as
5000 years ago or in 2001 as Rick turns
around he is face to face with his
eight-year-old son Alex but then the
next shot alex is a good two feet
shorter than Rick also I know your kid
is awesome and everything but why did
you bring him out here did the
babysitter not get him been again though
the better mousetrap your mother doesn't
discourage another tomb which is
something you think she'd be good at
avoiding since she's supposed to be an
Egyptologist know anybody how alluring
potential enemies to your presence
Evelyn can suddenly have visions now
which drive the plot and the movie gets
stuck I don't know I never real good
feeling about this there's no one
remember the acid salt trap from the
last movie clearly not because we're
still opening boxes with no concern for
the consequences and Hamid attained from
opening a check seriously do you
remember nothing huh
consume your way I let these guards who
apparently just died standing there have
a key to this box they were supposed to
be guarding it not taking it out to try
on every now and then when they pitched
this scene a studio executive said are
you sure this whole thing isn't just a
little too Indiana Jones and the
screenwriter replied no because we
replaced all the proper nouns and that
script with different proper nouns and
the studio controlled with it instead of
keeping his knife and his sheep on
climbing the ladder this guy decides to
put it in his mouth like he's a bad guy
from the streets of Agrabah how did the
water that was directly at their feet
managed and not completely engulf them
once they stopped running why is there a
sewer grate built into the floor here
it's almost like the ancient Egyptians
knew a movie was going to get made where
the heroes needed to escape and the
director would need an angle to show how
incredibly doomed they are Alex thinks
he can stop this several ton column from
falling with his eight-year-old strength
impossibly strong pillar or incredibly
weak asphalt
discuss what could the dead gives night
the book of the living takes life away
remember the epic destruction of the
city from the end of the last movie
there's no way in hell they would be
able to track these things down let
alone remain intact so they can be used
again if found can be on that wasn't the
city itself super hard to find
especially at night because it had that
dramatic sunrise reveal this group of
diggers waited around this bubbling spot
of land like a stripper was gonna pop
out instead of running for their lives
because something terrible was about
that these beetles are so much dumber
than the previous films beetles these
don't know the proper way to the human
brain end up just popping out of this
dudes mouth wasting everyone's time
you know just fell into that underworld
we pit at the end of the last movie so
why is he encased in amber like a
mosquito from Jurassic Park or that
remains unnoticed to me even though he's
wearing a different colored outfit than
everyone else and has those Kingma guy
tattoos on his face also come a guy for
continuing to suck at their job find out
later in the movie they have a helms
deep sized army yet they were unwilling
to stop these people from digging up the
mummy i bracelet firm such as dyes he
has no reason I think this bracelet is a
map but she's 100% right and then again
it was commanded by squirting g-guard
yes buddy I knew I just want to be 5000
years why would he awaken for any reason
didn't he sell his soul to Anubis for
eternity why would he be able to come
back after 5000 years also he says he
awakens every 5000 years like it's
happened several times in history before
when this would be the first time ever
and there's no evidence to support such
a claim looks like the black SUVs have
been replaced with old-timey Packard's
did the chest indicate that it wanted to
be open again course this makes the kids
curious so he'll open it to the block in
habit but you're telling me that chest
didn't do this once on the trip back to
London the bracelet that was designed to
fit on the scorpion the rock king's arm
it's nothing on this eight-year-old boy
you mentioned my feeling now is a good
time to mention that Alex is eight years
old and like I said the current year is
1933 and the first movie took place in
that means Alex was a year old when Evie
and Rick met which is a little awkward
if you ask me
concrete Jonathan just happens to be
holding something that is vital to their
mission I'm looking for the chest of
course I sure hope your kid wasn't
playing with whatever's in that chest
just before we got here and is currently
wearing it on his wrist but don't worry
I won't check the chest until it's too
late
totally he came to stop these guys than
a why didn't you do it before they got
to London when you so dramatically
looked off-camera to reveal that you
were in this movie and be bring more
guys no I did there was plenty of magic
my last film but trigger Eevee's
reincarnation abilities but for some
reason they don't start until the
beginning of this movie just a shoots
look out of the wall and nowhere near
Rick's location why does this guy kidnap
Evie didn't know that kidnapping her
would create a better character
motivation for Rick to go after them in
an attempt to make the story more
interesting Jonathan is covered in suds
then jumps out the window and found so
much that guy allow Evie to open this
curtain to show Rick but she's been
kidnapped she has attended the
stormtrooper school of shooting at
things and graduated with honors not
sure that's where ever this man and the
wife will surely be hey he's a traitor
lied to the British Museum and Rick
didn't know who once also how utterly
ridiculously convenient that this kid
not only knows what a bad guy asked but
he works at the British Museum and is
headed there right now to revive Imhotep
the heroes not only know who the bad guy
is but he's local
also it's never a good sign when your
eight-year-old son grabs a picture of an
older man you've never met and says hey
I know him I don't mean to point fingers
but isn't your job to make sure that
doesn't happen
a woman who is with him she knows this
is some classic avoiding the question
our death gets away with it they have
only seven days before the Scorpion King
awakens where we have seven days until
something terrible happens giving us
just enough time to do something about
it but not enough time for us not to be
stressed about a cliche O'Malley can
kill the Scorpion King can send his army
back to the envelope like his army I
thought it was anubis's army and you
just let him borrow it that one time
so that's why they dug up the only got
tough enough to take out the Scorpion
King this is how stupidly complex of a
stupid plan this is by the stupid bad
guys they want the army of Anubis but
they need to awaken the Scorpion came to
do that so to counter the Scorpion King
they decide to exhume Imhotep who
shouldn't even be a mortal anymore after
the last movie this is such a super bad
plan and I'm ready to turn the movie off
right now yes they could not well that
that MOC means you're a protector of man
a warrior for God a Magi we had fights
with the Magi all throughout the first
movie in this visible tattoo on his
wrist never came up these people find
both books and the key in the former
city of the Dead talking about finding
multiple needles in a city sized
haystack this time around reading from
The Book of the Dead wakes up every
nearby a mummy but first time it only
woke up a motel
it wasn't until later when Imhotep woke
up some of the other mummy dudes also
apparently I don't even need to be at
the ceremony to rise from the dead
I guess everyone should go check their
local cemetery for zombies right about
now you too Arkansas yep I felt it too
evening this movie is just about to go
all blue is the warmest color open this
bitch isn't it isn't it couple years ago
this would have seemed really strange to
me
Rick forgets that this strange stuff
that's no longer strange really happened
10 years ago going to this movies
timeline even though it's only been 2
years between mummy movies so we don't
actually need a key we just need some
acidic liquid and a syringe to open it
up got it Rick operates on to the scene
2x MOC another out of this movie why is
there still immortal the end of the last
movie made it clear he wasn't anymore
who can miss shelf of formaldehyde
inexplicably causes an explosion how
hard is it for you to mow all these
dudes down art out you have the high
ground and they have no cover well I was
forced to find an alternative means of
transportation did the bus driver leave
his keys in the bus and go get an ice
cream cone or did you and the
eight-year-old beat up a bus driver and
steal as buff these mummies have the
ability to jump through brick walls and
flatten cars but can easily be stopped
by a shotgun man where were those when
the other dude was fighting Rick these
mummies have exhibited super strength on
several occasions yet the fights with
humans seem to be evenly matched John
why are they stopping right now is it so
the kid can get kidnapped
these dudes somehow stealthily drove up
to the bus without anyone noticing and
grab the kid who luckily for them is
standing in the perfect place for a
kidnapping well so how did they even
know where to find these guys sure
they're driving a double-decker bus that
is now a single decker but they drove
all over London during that Matt chasing
the bad guys were way behind no doubt
Rick loves his kid but his love of
needing a car to track the bad guys down
should be greater in the first movie
Imhotep had a Sukkah dude dry to get a
tongue eyeballs and lips but here he
already has those things and he hasn't
killed anyone yet in case you confused
it with Cairo Sri Lanka powerful as he
was become he's still vulnerable I'm
trying to pinpoint this accent see from
Sesame Street it says there is one the
undead it was killed all those who open
this gym yes and the creature will suck
them dry and that he'd become whole
again
please don't tell me that the rules of
Imhotep from the first movie still apply
to this one it feels like a one-time
deal which required all sorts of ancient
Egyptian incantations and look there's a
process that needs to be followed for
this chest to be cursed again oh yes you
can we'll be just fine
it's just you unaware of the plan to
make them open the chest giving Imhotep
license to kill them why not just offer
them 50 they'll be dead soon anyway the
sands of time
I'm already be gone or against you and
luckily the frost Department for this
train sent me an hourglass to emphasize
my point seven days do I have lipstick
or pinking wake up did you also hear
that if you do not enter the tournament
before the Sun structured on that very
morning that the browser
her Luck's up this story sounds entirely
random like someone threw dirt to the
wheel applause my dad's going to kick
you aah I'm upset at this line not
because it's stupid it is but I think
I'm more upset that this kid is British
oh so does Imhotep just kill anyone who
was nearby oh and someone opens this
chest because he kills all of them but
Gareth over here is the only one who
opened it he motet spider-man organs how
many countless days did they spend
planning this dude in his magic airship
going to this movie it's about the same
amount of time it's going to take the
bad guys to get to their destination
using a shot Rick the good time actually
threatens this dude's life because he
doesn't have the vehicle he thought that
this guy had all for comedy
no no movie bloats run time with
annoying kid behavior Arnold Vosloo kemo
Jeff throws to random henchmen twenty
feet in the air how does this get Alex
back what purpose does is served
Alex managed to emergency stop the train
at a city where they're supposed to stop
anyway he acts like Japanese sighs were
used in ancient Egypt clearly in which
if knew someone that looked exactly like
Evy yet when he meets her in the first
movie he thinks she is his girlfriend
instead of thinking she's Nefertiti a
person he knew well back in the day now
the affair between Imhotep and anak soon
the moon is even dumber they did that
full view of the Pharaoh's Palace
if these curtains could be drawn why
bother making out the open Ruby
continues the myth that you can catch
somebody after they've fallen off the
edge of something and that you could
avoid falling yourself after making such
a catch but really though look what's
happening here did a knock suna moon
just pantomimes stabbed herself like
this is some high school black box show
does she really have to do all this over
a key Bowl so Imhotep can restore her
old soul to this new body also why go
through all the trouble this woman looks
exactly the same
and she's pretty similar in general
asshole we to the original so why bother
and that's the reason why we found the
bracelet exactly I was it protected
again why didn't you start having these
visions earlier that there's some cosmic
force that beckons you to protect the
bracelet but only a few weeks before the
Scorpion King awakens this was all
preordained thousands of years ago and
how does the story end only the journeys
written not the destination this is the
exact same model used to write the
script Alex left us his tie they've gone
to Szalai eight-year-old Alex can build
to scale sand castles of Egyptian ruins
that are never seen by his captors
right breadcrumbs
Alex was making his next sandcastle
right at Emma cups feet alex is really
banking on this whole groups extreme
ineptitude Lily couldn't find a real
River for Imhotep to get into so they
borrowed this fake one from a Nintendo
64 game well at the first movie was an
indication this mummy controlled water
will be just like the sand and do
absolutely nothing to stop the heroes as
illustrated here the water hits this out
of the air boat and causes absolutely no
casualties not only did Imhotep
needlessly chase them around with a
giant water head he led them right to
the Oasis the last time we saw a lock
nah he was right here far away from
where the heroes crashed
Imhotep looks satisfied they had killed
them with his amazing aqua so how did it
occur to him to run to the nearest cliff
just in case the bird happened to fly by
at this very moment I mean yeah we know
that he was wise to the bird way back in
scene 24 and was probably looking for a
good chance to kill it but there is no
way he got here in time to be in perfect
position to kill discount Hedwig it is
clear that ponce de leon was here to
torture mermaids for their tears and
bring from the fountain of anyway back
to the mummy returns but missed the last
five minutes what's happened something
he's coming it's me who he steals the
raptors in the weed scene from the lost
world he sliced his sword right across
his face but when we cut to him his face
neck and torso are all completely intact
and bloodless gunfire in the movie tries
to make us think that one of the main
characters got shot but in fact it's the
other guy who got shot by someone else
off screen cliche also it kind of feels
like Evelyn and Jonathan only appeared
in this action scene when their friends
and family really needed them I don't
think they killed one random bad guy
this whole time you'll be completely
ignores how the sunrise works Ana has
the light chase them from behind instead
of having it start at the top of the
pyramid and go down like a normal
real-life sunrise you know what this
bracelet it sole purpose is to wrap
around somebody's wrist
take them to several different locations
just to show them the next location and
then what the Scorpion King awakens no
matter what and you don't have any
control over a Moors army then when you
get to the place where he supposedly
rests the bracelet attaches what's the
goddamn point also stupid kid throws the
bracelet somewhere in the dirt instead
of simply hiding it somewhere thereby
leading to more unnecessary plot
complications with the power of Imhotep
and anak they could easily kill these
humans right now not decide not to
because of it would be charitable to
even say reasons I'm starting to think
that no one in this version of the
universe has blood is really wasting our
time by making us think Eevee is going
to die from this to the point that it
will require 13 seconds of dramatic
dissolves to sell the illusion
they are cool ving Tsun are like ooh you
are mortal you did no I'm not letting
that go probably send this more than
three times already but based on this
movie special effects I'm not sure if
the movie wants me to think these are
actual scorpions or shadows of scorpions
jungle anaconda I ever released the
automobile Mandal pieces why does the
army of Anubis get released by wearing
the bracelet and sticking your hand into
this scorpion statue
remember Alex was wearing the bracelet
and we need out of the pyramid the
bracelet like an asshole detached from
his wrist so if Alex wanted to release
the army of Anubis he would have had to
protect back on everyone involved in
this movie just needs to admit they had
no idea what the bracelet powers are or
the purpose of its existence army of
Anubis arrives in some nondescript area
that desert sort of right in front of
the pyramid it's also they knew they had
to fight them at first before receiving
any other commands sure I'm glad this
army is here to fight the army of Anubis
instead of preventing the release of the
army in the first place this time
someone taught you a lesson wench
come on this fools are not as emote it
beats this gong I'm wondering why the
Scorpion King isn't up yet
thought he was supposed to awaken from
the mere act of wearing a bracelet or
because he's supposed to awaken every
5000 years or some such this guy pressed
snooze on his sundial it's official the
supernatural mummy Monster is the only
one who complete but I'm just saying if
you can throw a sword at a member of the
army of Anubis and he immediately
disintegrates then maybe this army isn't
as awesome as it's been advertised maybe
this was a great army back in the bc but
here in the OC now bit something like
that also instead of holding on to a
sword and using it when it gets close to
the next soldier our guess decides to
throw a sword leaving an unarmed for an
unsettling amount of time in battle a
shock head Jesus Alex how long is this
incantation oh you kid you know
everything you and this movie god damn
it you mean the exact symbol that
Jonathan had to figure out from the last
movie that's motherfucking amazing also
why is a Knoxville fighting Jonathan
what Alex is reading from the book it
should be way more concerned with Alex
at this point remember the whole reason
she's fighting Jonathan is because he's
a distraction not a real threat fact
it's downright unbelievable this trained
warrior hasn't killed him yet
The Scorpion King is brought to you by
the Industrial Light and Magic summer
intern Edie started out just receiving a
flashback here and there from a previous
life but now she is suddenly endowed
with all her former selves combat skills
I need to bring you up here to the
ceiling of my lair and tear you to
pieces I couldn't do it down on the
floor or just
are you in keep fighting Rick because
dismemberments are so much fun oh man
there's more army headed this way
but they're way better than that last
army that was thoroughly defeated but
the movie has ten minutes left so you
know these assholes are going back to
the underworld before these guys have to
fight them god dammit
really Rick is just going to walk up to
a carving that has a picture of his
tattoo and the spear his
brother-in-law's been carrying around
and give him step-by-step directions on
how to kill the Scorpion King I want to
go home to a movie but at least I'm
trying and amazing this was acceptable
back in 2001 like they released the
movie with no regrets and everything
thank god this thing was in slow-mo so
that Rick could catch the spear in
midair
Rick barely falls into the underworld
and has lost forever in the shot but by
the time it gets back to him he somehow
hanging onto the ledge by his boots I
wouldn't be shocked at this point they
told me that there was a prophecy that
foretold that Rick would be wearing tar
Laden boots while fighting the Scorpion
King and that they activate near
underworlds not someone defeats the
Scorpion King they don't get to keep the
Oasis for themselves or anything it
triggers a complete self-destruct
forcing our characters to run some more
this skilled fighter is floated by a
pratfall into a tub of scorpions that
are inexplicably staying in their spot
The Mummy Returns CGI budget was clearly
in the black after rendering the
Scorpion King so they blew the rest of
the money on this sequence and 8-ball
and some hookers spear mate has a lone
upper floor exit just in case you're
caught inside while the Oasis is getting
sucked back in they use is machina this
sands flows and didn't bring down the
dirigible a second time
[Music]
we seem to be made to suffer it's our
lot in life we need a magic carpet
[Music]
my gift is my so where are you on the
father-son but I know something I don't
but I know something about you you with
the quiz work at the private pool
[Music]